grégoire c'est très simple on va jouer
tous les deux vous allez devoir mettre
votre pinceau vous et regardez vous
venez mon pinceau pour regarder vous
avez on a on a deux pôles y en a un avec
la peinture est un sans peinture vous
allez devoir mettre votre pinceau dans
un dépôt tahri en fait nous mettez les
deux pinceaux dans les deux camps les
petits ok ça vous pouvez vous pouvez
vous pouvez changer les trucs ce que je
sais pas ce qu'il ya et je vais choisir
une main et vous allez me mettre un coup
de pinceau sur la tête si c'est la
peinture j'aurais de la peinture si
c'est pas de la peinture je n'aurai pas
de peinture et a bien sûr l'attention on
y va je vous laisse faire avec vos pots
on va démarrer par les deux petits
pinceaux
j'ai pris les deux pieds pinceau ce prêt
est prêt
cette droite qui ont coché répond pas
répond pas bon on va me dire
françois mois coquinou c'est toi le fou
j'ai chanté
vous êtes droitier ou gaucher
je suis le gaucher de paul prédault au
je suis là pourquoi parce que moi je
suis gaucher donc à gauche pour moi il
ya là approche son beau minois coco
attention aux passants compacité
au parc brocante sur mon dos et ça va je
suis pas dupe acquis chez un tien tu
n'as pas volé celle ci entre en guerre
koné d'acteurs de prison break away
il a tatoué dans son dos le truc pour
s'enfuir des limites à toi tu ressembles
à jean luc reichmann là
je vais
j'en étais
jean luc et rigolard et vers la la la
je vais vous dire là il nous a fait
inédit semoun c12 et michelot c'est mal
à la une par émission maintenant je vais
mettre en place un téléphone rouge que
ferait michel drucker dans une telle
situation
qu'est ce que dirait michel drucker jean
luc sais rien merci j'en ai et eric
messer dans l'est le procès d'un train
de rire ici la tâche aussi on a grandi à
l'est et a remis 2 3 attention grégoire
grégoire comme les tartelettes
je vais prendre je vais rester sur mon
premier choix à savoir se bat
à toi grégoire le moment je change le
chanteur dans tout paris bruisse il
prend suis là je suis là parce que je
change allez tu change pas ce que tu
aimes le changement ça dépend quel sens
mais parce que j'aime bien toutes les
stations ferment les yeux
foot la pousse vers mairie
coke
bon le noir
ça vous va super bien
j'adore les mois et vachement dans ma
période avengers en plus donc je me sens
mais les gars qui arrive à l'antenne à
la feuille d'un nouveau design nouvel
album là vous êtes bon la marque est
vachement bien fait corps sexués ou non
mais c'est vrai moi c'était si c'est une
belle peinture c'est vrai mais vous
c'est vrai que c'est bien fait c'est toi
qui l'a fait non mais non c'est pas bon
ça vous fait voilà bourse